alors après on va faire maintenant une
interview qui s'appelle l'interview nul
en un mot ce patrimoine pendant le
génial le mouchoir dans le sillage alors
première question est ce que vous
préfériez votre père ou votre mère ça
dépend des moments de ma vie
ouais est ce que vous préférez hitler ou
staline
je n'ai ni l'un ni l'autre alors vous
devez partir de 3 ans dans un vaisseau
spatial vous préféré partir avec gérard
muller au moins leur compte par les crs
car celle d' où elie wiesel offres
conduit un match de rêve elle me dit
l'aîné ce soir non on ne peut discuter à
la discussion avec mais pour combien de
temps d'enlever trois ans 3 ans et 3 ans
les deux autres trois en effet les
visuels ces temps-ci là il est libre
alors savez vous ce qu'est devenu jean
roucas
non est ce que vous préférez un
président d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou en annuler les
élections
là je préférerais qu'on nous annule son
site web vous avez vu ce que ça a donné
en algérie quand on a dû les élections
parce qu'elle nous déplaisaient journal
aussi à des élections et des élections
gérard ben je me permets de rappeler m
février trek il sait aussi bien que
n'importe qui que hitler est venu au
pouvoir par des élections
mussolini reçu par exemple il c'est bien
pour se le disait tout à l'heure que les
allemands et les nazis c'était la même
chose
puis gelé la demoiselle a également vu
plus haut les signes de la main sur rome
hitler c'est vraiment les élections et
le problème de la démocratie c'est
qu'elle est assez fait pour laisser
parfois venir à sa tête des gens qui
veulent la d'esprit et oncle du mot
crossfit fille
je trouve simplement qu'il faut faire en
sorte que les ennemis de la démocratie
n'est pas la possibilité tout le liban
une démonstration d'unité c'est ça moi
tu bruno grossi
si vous pouviez avoir un truc en plus
vous choisiriez année
un oeil ou un saint comme adamo 3 ça oui
ah bon
un deuil ou un saint lô l'oeil derrière
bris derrière vous partez sur une île
déserte pendant deux ans cette fois vous
préféré partir avec un maître très beau
ou une fille très moche je suis très
moche en deux ans deux ans et dit sa
partie avec jarre milliards dans
l'espace demande pas pardon aux éditions
du rocher
c'est parce que vous avez fait un gérant
mineurs mais j'ai jamais vu comme ça il
est d'un calme
c'est l'idée de faire seulement existé à
vos provocations
non je dois dire que la présence de lou
doillon et puis moi justifie la mienne
oui et que dès que je vais peut-être un
peu mans portées contre certains propos
certains souvenirs de propos tenus par
monsieur grise et je regarde nous le
voyons et quelques mots qu'elle a dit et
sa présence suffisent à las vegas je
voulais dire en fait c'est quand j'avais
mon talent de et que vous regardiez
claude sarraute ça vous n'êtes pas le
même effet de bout en bout et on aurait
vu verdict et les héninois y ont été
abordés